i'm going to give you all three tips at
once and then i'll explain them okay so
here we go just one two three the tips
are diagrams diagrams and diagrams okay
now I know right okay I I'm half joking
a half jerky um my first tip is diagrams
and it is it's diagrams diagrams
diagrams if you wrote diagrams three
times you know what I have no problem
with that because because we talked
about this before but this is geometry
and in many ways this will make or break
you as a geometer that's actually the
like what more people who is mad at you
um you must draw diagrams you must draw
a decent diagrams if you try and do a
question without diagrams just be
prepared to fail and fail for a long
time okay there's a reason why diagrams
are so powerful you know when they say a
picture is a thousand words well
sometimes it's more sometimes I often as
as we get into circle geometry you'll
see this even more I'll stare at a
question they give me a diagram and I'll
stare at it and i'll just get nowhere
and so i put pen to paper i might even
just be copying down there diagram and
then the answer will click in my mind
okay um you need to use diagrams to
understand you need to use diagrams to
explain your answer as well and you need
to choose diagram to construct your
solution okay so please don't skimp on
the diagrams okay and they need to be a
decent size we've talked about all that
before I just want to mention it again
okay secondly when it comes to um you
know because between a person that kinda
thing when it comes to reasoning i'm
going to give you here's my tip which is
frustratingly vague but i can't i can't
make it any more specific in his way
okay in the syllabus when it talks about
like this standard over or you know how
many like can-can abbreviations be used
what symbols can be used what notation
can be used to substitute for words and
that kind of thing there is no acepta
list there is no acceptable is
for like what terms can just be like
contracted what can I just use an
acronym for etc right there can't be
intercepted this because it's not about
like a bunch of it's not like a game
with a bunch of rules right it's just
about are you communicating clearly can
someone read your proof can someone read
what you have done and clearly
understand what you have communicated
right and depending on the context
depending on the person who's reading it
right it will be different things for
different people right when you see SSS
like I think I know what that means like
well it depends on the context
completely generally we're quite okay
with that because it's clear given all
of the things that are going to surround
when you right SAH right but sometimes
it's not like I've seen students write
this and expect me to know what they're
talking about it's like is it co
interior is a corresponding is a
complementary it could be yeah it's like
it's like I wrote this cuz I didn't know
which what it was i knew i was one of
them I this is not clear this is not
quick or you know people write this
right what does that mean it's like it's
I I don't really know especially the
fact that par isn't is its own word okay
that's not helpful okay these things are
not clear they are not clear right so
you will not ever get a list of yet
these will always be accepted but you
need to test for yourself when you look
back at this thing or when you hand it
to someone else and they read it is it
obvious what you mean the actual phrase
in the syllabus is the student must make
it clear in italics underline bulb
that's all it says right so you're going
to come to me and you're gonna ask me
you know is this acceptable and I'm
going to say to you is it clear okay now
I'll admit I love me I have a slight leg
up on you because I see you know many
more solutions than you guys have and
I've seen Matt in a much more different
context that you guys have so i will
have sort of like a better idea of what
is clear or not but you can still answer
this question yourself right verbally
have you made it clear what you are
trying to
okay right if you want to earn the side
of having less rather than more go for
it the person who is reading your
solution might be able to clearly
understand but they might not so you are
taking a risk if you want to take that
risk you go ahead so long as you
understand it's a risk does that make
sense anyone have any questions on that
to find me on velocity for now yeah sure
so the reason why we do that is because
if early on we make we play very fast
and loose with like yeah anything you
like right it's kind of a little bit
like I people get the wrong idea and
they lose the rigor of a proof and they
can just like oh I can just write
anything and then it's fine it's like
what you can't if you were communicating
with like normal human beings you can't
just say anything and expect that other
people who magically read your mind and
know what you mean right and so we start
the bar saying look beers like right
this exact set of words and have in that
exact order the truth is like real
mathematics is not like that i can i can
think of for example one of most i'm one
of those classic ones is this he's well
it's the morning okay here's a circle
okay if you have a tangent like so and
then you do this oh okay if you have an
angle between the tangent and this cord
over here is a cord right the court
every chord every chord divides up a
circle into two parts right what are
these two parts called starts where's it
called segments right segments okay so
here's an angle over here and there's
another angle over here in this segment
not not the one that this egg goes in in
the other one right so we don't want to
say oh the other one my technical word
for that is alternate okay now that's a
segment that's the alternate segment the
angle in the alternate segment is equal
to the angle between the tangent in the
cord that made that segment that's
called the alternate segment here okay
now i could say
the angle in this segment is equal to
the angle between the tangent and the
core that formed in the alternate
segment and that would be exactly right
I could save the alternate segment
theorem and that might also be exactly
right but there's like in between that
first thing I said and that last answer
there's 10 different ways a hundred
different ways to say what I'm actually
referring to and they kind of all okay
because they're all clear no they're not
in exactly the same word order because
they have like you know they have the
angle between the tangent and the cord
at the beginning of the sentence or at
the end of the sentence or whatever but
are they clear no mathematician is going
to say but ridiculous it sentences
backwards you know if it's clear it's
mathematically sound right so you're not
going to get one which is like memorize
that because that's not the way
mathematics actually fundamentally is